the jurgen experience during times of
great prosperity
being a hoe is a choice yeah right but
there's a lot of reluctant hoes
i'm i'm i'm a scared hoe on the inside
i'm like i'm a bad [ __ ] i listen to meg
the stallion cardi b
wet ass plus he's my anthem and then
like i'll talk to a guy on a dating app
and i'm like
uh uh do you want to go to the park and
like i don't know
what do you want to do even though you
enjoy those art forms and people's
expression in general you're a pretty
calm
person yeah that's why yeah you like
that music because it's fun but that's
not that doesn't define you
no how funny was that ben shapiro thing
oh my
god the wet ass [ __ ] thing you said my
god that's a result of a gynecological
situation yeah
how did he say it i don't even know he
like was reading them and he's like well
in conclusion what else [ __ ] is
actually not that wet
uh um ben
benny stay in your lane bunny boy oh my
god i mean i like ben shapiro
let me just state this i think uh people
get the wrong impression about him all
the time i think he's a very nice guy
he's a very smart guy
but he uh he has his blind spots like we
all do
and when you think that wet ass [ __ ]
is a gynecological condition
whoops let me tell you something
[Laughter]
the mass humiliation of ben shapiro i
don't like him
he scares me i like him as a human i
know him as a human being and that's a
problem
like you see someone who does like
performative work
about politics because part of what he
does is funny like he has a mug that
says leftist tears
you know and he serves you water like
when ezra klein from vox was on his show
he drank out of a cup that said
leftist tears and they were actually
talking about it like he's like
like don't you think this is it he's
like i think it's funny yeah
he leans into it look he's good guys
just not perfect
not like all of us that's the thing like
you want to find one thing wrong with
the person and [ __ ] hate him yeah and
that's
just silly yeah you can still think he's
a nice guy and still think it's [ __ ]
silly to make fun of wet [ __ ] totally
or it's like i might not like the guy
but i don't need to like
attack him yeah i'm telling you but he
does have a goofy ass
little smirk well he's he's a
professional look
one of the reasons why people love floyd
mayweather is because he talks
so much [ __ ] he talks so much hit he's
always showing his money
he's kind of trolling in a way that's
become such a thing in fighting and then
well with him he was so good at it
because
he was a guy who was uh very safety
first as a boxer like
incredibly skillful like arguably the
best boxer of all time
but he he didn't go
after guys and just engage in wars he
fought very tactically
and he's fighting the best fighters in
the world so he has to fight
very cautiously sometimes that's the
correct way to do it
but he figured out a way to get people
to pay attention because
that generally like being the most
skillful is great
but you want people to pay attention so
you want to be like a mike tyson guy who
knocks everybody out
well if you're not a mike tyson guy that
knocks everybody out the best way to get
people to pay attention is
make them want you to lose show them all
your money
oh look at that watch it's a million
dollars yeah look at this hat look at
these diamonds look at this and look at
this jet i just flew in a [ __ ] and get
[ __ ]
yeah no and you just want to beat him up
you want him to get his ass kicked but
meanwhile he's
the best boxer ever and so he's just out
boxing all these people and he never
gets his ass kicked
it's kind of funny i mean if you really
pay attention to it it's kind of fun
well ben shapiro is
that's kind of what he does he's like
says things knowing it's going to piss
people off and then they're paying
attention to him yeah but he also says
some things that make sense
he's very good at debate he's very good
at uh arguing
with uh uneducated people who just
like automatically subscribe to
left-wing ideas he can chop those up
quick if you don't have your
your thoughts dialed in and your
argument dialed in
but he's you know he's a person yeah
he's a very nice guy
we're all people just people why can't
we all just get along
i know this is the this is the if i can
you know people oh it's [ __ ] easy for
you guys you're [ __ ] making money
you're a comedian you're listening
you're right but what ali's saying
if we just be nicer to each other is the
solution
[Applause]